ههه على واقع الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي بنجبير للساحات
المسجد الاقصى سرعت اسرائيل الى رفع حاله
التاهب خاصه على حدود قطاع غزه خشيه من
اطلاق صواريخ وخوفا من عدم اختصار ردود
الفعل الشعبي والرسميه الفلسطينيه على
بيانات التمديد والاستنكار الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي يرضى بتمرير هذه الجرائم
اليوميه من اقتحامات للاقصى وكانت
لقتحامات تتم على يد المستوطنين الان تتم
اعياد الحكومه الاسرائيليه يعني انا اعتقد
اراد نتنياهو ان يضع قواعد جديده للعبه في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وانا اقول انه
سيتحمل المسؤوليه عن نتائج هذه اللعبه لان
اللاعب بالمسجد الاقصى المبارك هو بالعاده
لعب بالنار بالتجربه عام 67 وحتى اللحظه
وكان الوزير المتطرف بين كبير لجا الى نوع
من الخدعه حيث اشعه ان اقتحامه الاقصى
تاجل بعد تحفظ نتنياهو لكن الرجلين كانت
اتفق على الاقتحام مسبقا
تم مده 13 دقيقه فقط بشكل غير معلن اما
نتنياه فتجاهل الحديث عن الاقتحام في جلسه
الحكومه وفضل التحدث عن ايران
الاتفاق النووي الخطير شطب عن طاوله البحث
بعد الاحداث الاخيره في ايران اعتقد بان
هذه الامكانيه ما زالت قائمه ولم تنتهي
في حكومه ان عضو فيها لن تكون هناك تفرقه
عنصريه اليهود سيصعدون لجبل الهيكل ونوضح
لحماس اننا لن نتراجع وفي العوده الى
الاقتحام فان بين كبير سبق وانت سبب
بالحرب الاخيره على قطاع غزه بعد
اقتحاماته متكرره لساحات الاقصى وحي الشيخ
جراح لكن الاقتحام الحالي يبدو مغيرا بعد
ان اصبح في موقع صنع قرار يعرف بين كبير
في اسرائيل بانه مشعله حرائق التقليديه
وقد وضع حاليا بالقرب من برميل من البارود
واقتحامه للمسجد الاقصى سيصب الزيت على
نار المواجهه مع الفلسطينيين الذين يقولون
بان التطرف لم يعد تصريحات او شعارات وان
ممارسه على الارض زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الشرقيه المحتله